that's we'll see chris paddock for the
first time since his rookie season the
first time they saw him at petco park
two years ago he was just magnificent he
was and he was known more as a fastball
change up pitcher he's using his
curveball a lot more now as a fine
pitcher a young pitcher that had a
difficult april he really brought it
together in may june has been good the
first battle of the game billy mckinney
steps in and we are set to go and right
into the teeth of the shift
out number one so that'll bring up
francisco lindor who's really eating up
now swinging a miss good curveball from
panic and he strikes out lindor out
number two in the top of the first and
that'll bring up the number three hitter
pete alonso he and panic had a little
rivalry there a couple of years ago fly
ball to right field and myers moves over
to make the catch chris paddock a one
two three top of the first on the mound
for the mets is marcus strowman and the
right-hander the veteran the erstwhile
blue jay
makes the start this afternoon
two-seamer slider a dominant pitch
throws the cutter a split finger as well
along you know he'll mix in a
four-seamer and a curveball makes his
12th start
and this guy when he is on his game he
gets a lot of ground balls he's going to
go after tommy pham and fam reaches for
it pokes it out to right but there's
mckinney to grab it for the first down
and that'll bring up jerickson pro farm
swinging her hard hit grounded at first
gobbled up by alonso he trusts the bag
in time and there are two men away
here's jay cronin worth batting third in
the order he's lined into center field
that'll get down for a base hit two out
single jake cronenworth round one goes
to the padre and now fernando tatis jr
will bat here in the first swing of the
miss gets away and taking second base is
proto work that's going to be a pass
ball this is one of the results of
catchers trying to frame pitches and
chronoworth stands at second base
instantly into scoring position here
with two down and he goes to the slider
gets a half swing and he went around for
strike three tatis fussing with tripp
gibson who did not ask for help the home
plate umpire called it himself strowman
gets the strikeout and puts the padres
down in the first dominic smith will
lead off against chris paddock and dom
tries to hold up and he stopped the
swing in time ball four so this is the
kind of thing that irritates teams right
tatis is up the home plate umpire calls
it and now gibson doesn't call this time
and he's getting it from the bench and
tingler's coming out and now tangler's
been thrown out of the game so jace
tingler and you can understand exactly
what his frustration level is you you
called it yourself
on the one to tatis which didn't really
look much like a swing
and here on a similar play you asked for
help so that is uh that's the fourth
ejection in this series so with all of
that the bits have a lead off runner and
james mccann will be the better runner
go swing and a miss the roar down there
is in time
strike him out throw him out double play
webster rivas adds another guy to his
list just like that two outs here in the
second so the mets have a runner a third
for the first time and billy mckinney
will have a chance to get the mets on
top here and he lines one to center
field that's a base set and that'll
bring in the game's first run and the
mets have the early lead one nothing in
the third stroman issues back-to-back
walks and that'll bring cronenworth to
the play with two men on ronan worth
muscles one on the ground down to first
and alonzo takes it himself that retires
the side dom smith will now step in
smith in the last nine games shooting at
385 with an ops over a thousand and
smith slugs one out to center back goes
pro far to the track at the wall and
it's out of here
dom smith clears the center field fence
for his fourth home run of the year his
second home run on this road trip and
the mets now have a two nothing lead and
now here's mccann
one hopper to ease
his throwing hop he's in time
i don't know how he did that
exploding grounder that he picks and
then fires on a hop spectacular play
that is a brilliant play by fernando
tatis a couple of hits bracketing a walk
and strowman has trouble to deal with in
the fourth now you've got reevos the
rookie catcher with the base is loaded
it's pulled on the ground right at the
bag at third the glove on the bag the
floor the first double play side retired
brandon drury making a terrific play
right at the third base bag to start the
5-5-3 double play and get strowman
through the inning in the scoring
position now two down here in the fifth
inning his fan and jake cronin worth
coming up cornerworth with a check swing
chopper drury with a running toss and
that retires the side strowman for a
second straight start turns in five
scoreless innings moves mckinney over to
third with one out and paddock will stay
in the face alonso has been up twice in
this game and flied out both times and
it's lined to center field and pete's
got to base it and that'll bring it a
run mckinney comes in to score alonso
with the rbi single and the mets
stretched their lead to three nothing
marcus strowman will face the middle of
the san diego batting order beginning
with fernando tatties junior and a
grounder back to strowman
he's got a gold glove but he throws it
away
and fernando will go to second base and
now throwing it away is alonzo
that'll go all the way towards the
padres dugout as fernando will take
third base
what a mess that was the mets give the
padres life in the sixth inning here's
hosmer chopped right side alonzo will go
to strollman and in the back door is
tatise
he scores the first run of the day for
the padres two odds in a rudder at first
so strowman's going to take the turn and
bat and stay in to pitch the bottom of
the seventh all right hit a double
that's pitchers hit well with this
ballpark and he rips one
down the left field line and that's
going to go into the corner perrazzo on
his way to third he's going to be waved
home marcus strowman with an rbi double
and it's four to one new york look at
strowman at second base marcus strowman
after his hitting heroics in the top of
the inning goes back to the mound for
the bottom of the seventh that one jams
reevos and he floats one out to shore it
where lindor is there to field it and
throw him out here's jorge mateo who
came in the double switch last inning
half swing did he go around they check
it first and he went around matteo is a
strikeout victim that's going to be off
for strowman he goes six and two thirds
he'll exit after the double by fam job
well done by strowman leaves without
having a lot of nerd run alonzo still at
first two men away that'll bring up
james mccann swinging a high fly ball
well hit left center it's deep pro far
back he jumps can't get it home run
james mccann a two-run homer and the
mints have opened up a 6-1 lead newman
pitcher right-hander trevor may
one out first and third for tommy pham
on the ground to short diving stop
lindor backhand flip they get the out
there as a run comes home
lindora though saves a hit with a
beautiful diving play and they get the
second out but now the padres down to
their final out down by four swinging a
miss strike three put it in the books
and the mets have come back to split
this four game series with the san diego
padres